so recently someone asked is it ok to
consume the psalm ik vinegar ok so I
told her to start reading the labels
because they very okay like here's a
brand right here in this entire
container there's actually 33 servings
okay 1 tablespoon equals one serving so
in 1 tablespoon this has 3 grams of
sugar now this next one right here has 4
grams of sugar okay it's pretty high per
tablespoon and here's one right here
that has 5 grams of sugar per tablespoon
others have 9 grams of sugar per
tablespoon that is way way too high what
you have to realize is your there's no
fiber and this is just pure liquid and
it's going to spike your blood sugars
because it's high on the glycemic index
now it is true that you are allowed 20
to 50 grams of carbs per day but just
realize we're talking about low glycemic
type carbs we're not talking about
something high on the glycemic index
it's much better if you use apple cider
vinegar which has zero carbohydrates in
zero sugars okay now if you still want
to use the Soumik vinegar make sure you
read the label and get the one that's
only 2 grams per tablespoon now if
you've been having a hard time losing
weight and getting into ketosis this
could be the culprit right here because
it's it was actually quite surprising
how much sugar about a lot of these
brands hat alright guys I'll see you
next video
so I'm really excited to tell you about
a new contest we just started that
revolves around our subscribers now if
you're not a subscriber you definitely
want to subscribe right now because
we're gonna randomly select one winner
each month okay for the next year this
month we're going to be giving away my
electrolyte powder we're gonna randomly
select someone and then we'll do a video
on it now this electrolyte powder is
very unique it's very different than
anything you've ever had not only is it
going to give you endurance when you
exercise and just give you more energy
make you feel more hydrated but there's
over 4,000 milligrams of potassium there
is tons of magnesium
there's the trace minerals there's no
multi dextran it actually tastes really
good too it's lemon raspberry flavor and
a lot of people take it to get into
ketosis a lot faster and smoother so if
you're not a subscriber subscribe now so
you can enter to win